all right everybody so with Deadpool to
now in the world and out there a lot of
people are talking about the way that
the movie ends and those really amazing
post credit sequences Eric actually
already made a breakdown of those scenes
that you definitely go check out but
here we're gonna talk about the way that
Deadpool twos ending sets up a potential
situation for the upcoming Deadpool
sequels and where we think that might go
so is there a Deadpool trilogy or even
more how will Domino or cable play into
it
let us know you guys thoughts well it's
gonna make enough money for at least
Drew Goddard x-force movie because
that's what they're definitely setting a
good but it I'm gonna be bummed if Peter
doesn't show up for just like I say like
maybe the guy in the chair we set up
that joke in spider-man homecoming
that's a guy in the chair Peter gets to
do that or at least he gets he brings
brownies for everybody he's a villain
I'm he's so good a lot of people thought
he was gonna be Pete wisdom from the
comics who's he's not that know so much
better it's so much better than not so
he's a guy who can like shoot laser
knives out of his fingers
tortas amazing I just want that light
for him there's no way they're not
making a Deadpool three also though like
that me I don't know if they'll make
more than that because I don't think
anyone's gonna play Deadpool besides
Ryan Reynolds it's not unless I mean for
a long time unless they introduce some
sort of strange spin-off but like I
think that they'll make three and they
definitely make x-force and then pivot
and they talked about or ryan reynolds
mentioned that in a third deadpool movie
if it happened like hypothetically that
he'd want it to be smaller than this
like because this is pretty this is big
there's a lot of people now yeah luckily
they killed off so many but talking
about the characters that are still
there we still have Domino we have
negasonic teenage warhead we have Yuki
ho now we have fire fist and call Peter
so which of these characters do we
expect to definitely return you Colossus
you grated they feel like they were
setting that up honestly I think the one
that could carry and pivot like if they
were to focus on one character and like
give Ryan Reynolds a break Domino
that's a lot fledged out there and I
think that she could really carry the
franchise with a lot of people like
asking for more female centric like
superhero movies Domino would be a
really smart decision like it cuz you
could also like you could take some of
the like strong female characters
already have like negasonic and longest
name ever and yukio but you could also
take in everybody else like the eques
didn't even mention by the x-men little
cameo was amazing in this movie so you
could maybe even borrow some characters
from there it wouldn't it wouldn't be a
bad idea when my favorite idea is that I
was just sitting there in in watching
Deadpool 2 and I was thinking you know
Domino it seems unstoppable and I think
that actually that'd be an interesting
thing to portray in the next movie
she also in a way can really do Deadpool
and that she can't really die either at
least not but if it's not by her own
choosing right like if she doesn't well
if she wants to make it out of a
situation
she will every single time so I was like
how do we actually follow that thread
and figure out what is her worst case
scenario so that she does maybe die and
just my Brian my Brian but he he told me
in my head um that I'm a bad boy we're
never gonna make it your family but he
also told me what about the idea of
Domino set up in a situation where it
actually would be better for her to die
or a situation where it's more lucky for
her to let someone she cares about a lot
where the world would be better off if
she died whatever or just like if I'm
gonna I'm not gonna die instantly or I'm
gonna be a burn victim and have to
suffer a lot of pain or ever like there
are scenarios where it'd be luckier to
just die or it'd be luckier for instance
if it's between her and her her
girlfriend or boyfriend or something
like that and like it's more lucky for
her for them to die there's just ways to
like make it a very dark situation for
you you know you have to find her
kryptonite because that's exactly what
is it that could bring her down and I
think that's an interesting part it
doesn't becomes more from Ryan but yeah
I think you know finding like a dude the
rocks I was like hi I'm probability
well in comics it's usually never just
like everything happens and it's good
for her it's always just at the last
second it's like and she falls out of a
car she doesn't die but she breaks your
arm and so it's it's luck but it's not
like wish-granting so I hear it kind of
felt like it was but like you could dial
it back a little bit which wouldn't hurt
this movie in any way it's just like no
it doesn't doesn't mean everything works
out it's like I'm still gonna get hit
I'm still gonna maybe get shot but that
I can still survive and I can still help
yes really yeah yeah really quick about
cable though for those that read the
comics obviously cable and Deadpool have
a lot of story that could be told there
do you guys think that's gonna be in the
sequels I wonder that the the the other
scenario I thought because yeah they
could do so much with that but I also
thought now they could have used this
movie as a way to just introduce him
into the x-men universe now because he
is you know Scott Summers son so it's
like they could have he could appear in
what is it Dark Phoenix which is done
shooting but he already shot scenes for
that the people don't know about
yes he's now introduced in this movie
and it would kind of make totally unless
I mean it would really shoot rather him
be and that's a situation where he fits
a little bit for me that's like a
selfish thing of well he's a great
character and in that whole story oh
yeah yeah I understand why people would
want him in Deadpool movies but like it
definitely takes away from the insanity
of Deadpool if cables there which is
maybe not a bad thing but if people like
the like silliness of the movies cable
is a downer
I like the buddy cop I want another
buddy cop thing yeah or Sonya but I try
to have sex on sighs all right how about
this those sound like our prediction so
let us know what you guys have is
predictions for the behavior in a way
for sighs that's my prediction in the
comments below just fill it with ideas
for Deadpool 3 and so on and so on I
remind her to subscribe to this channel
because we got a lot of Deadpool
coverage too I don't know if you notice
see we got a lot of infinity war stuff
as well it's somewhere on bears to check
that out thanks everybody